the problem we have
you know at all the things that you
mentioned you know the grid issues the
electro
electrical grid uh the water uh basins
you know are they uh are they
problematic could they be yeah they
could be
but the bottom line is cyber
is probably one of the deadliest threats
we face today
as a national security risk because you
have russia
you have china you have el salvador
iran north korea north korea
these are all you know they all have
their elements out there
that are trying to attack the u.s
without doing it publicly and how do you
do that you get into the banking systems
you get into systems like this
they could do a lot of damage a lot of
damage
and that's what we have to worry about
and and here's what's interesting
can you pull up that tweet that i sent
you this is this is pretty insane to be
thinking about how ridiculous this is
getting
here's u.s consumer product safety
commission
do not fill plastic bags with gasoline
yeah plastic bags
plastic bags with gasoline what do you
mean plant do you even have to
tweet about the fact that the only
reason they're tweeting that is why
because someone's dude maybe they think
it's a water bag or something hey let me
go fill up plastic how do you even fill
up plastic
this is this one this is what irrational
actors
are thinking about when they hear that
there's a gas shortage and they don't
own one of the big red buckets because
homeboy over there just bought
ten thousand and put them in his truck
and now your only option is i got to go
fill up a garbage bag versus gasoline
and you're freaking out like you said
they're uninformed and they're just
acting
so so here's what we want this is the
largest u.s pipeline
number one largest u.s fuel pipeline
okay
dark dark side hackers took a hundred
gigabyte of data they stole
okay they have a uh a double extortion
scheme
there's a ransom they want here in
return if you go look up who dark side
hackers are
they operate on the dark web it's not
political they flat out tell you we are
not political we don't lean on the left
or the right or anywhere
we simply just want money on their
website they tell you which
companies they've attacked which
companies they've hacked
what they've gotten on their website
clearly and they say they have a very
value-based principle
they don't go after funeral homes they
don't go after insurance companies they
don't go after
companies that take care of a elderly
they're they're such
oh what nice the principle
thieves principle principle-based
hackers and uh uh biden came out and
said look this has nothing to do with
uh russia uh meaning the government it
has something to do with
the the the people that are hacking are
from russia but
we don't know if they're linked to
russia or not obviously gas price is one
of the highest
in seven years but if you really think
about it here's what you got to be
thinking about
so go and think about what kova did to
us for 12 months
how much should kova cost us i was
talking to noam chomsky
and he said such an interesting thing he
said look what
osama bin laden did to u.s he said osama
bin laden during bush and obama
he got the u.s government his goal was
to make us government go bankrupt
chasing this guy u.s spent 3.6 trillion
dollars just to catch this guy
he says what human being in the world
has
ever been worth 3.6 trillion dollars
the most expensive human being ever in
the world
was osama bin laden think about that the
most expensive human being in the world
was osama bin laden that's how much you
have spent
to go capture this skill right 3.6
trillion dollars so now
you come back and look at something like
this how much should covet cost u.s
how much cost five trillion plus sold so
far
in excess of five in excess of 5.6 okay
five to six trillion dollars forget
about the printing money all this stuff
five to six trillion dollars right and
now things are coming back that
uh you know fauci was part of a funded
project i don't know if you saw that or
not that they
helped out with china years ago and now
they're kind of wanting to remove their
names but on the bottom of it this lady
who did
this a report on the bottom she says
that this research was funded by i think
it's nih which
fauci's name is on that now faction's
coming back and saying we had nothing to
do with this
and they're saying how reckless this
could have been because the virus could
have come out et cetera et cetera
what does this have to do with covert
and fauci here's what it has to do with
it
the the threats you know you know how
they say what is that one line you know
if wars were fought in you know
uh the next world war three will be
fought with what sticks and bones you
know sticks and uh with words
no no no no sticks and stones meaning
it's gonna be the end of the world
they're gonna i don't think that's gonna
be the case
if you actually think about what the
next wars are gonna be the toughest
things about the next war is you don't
know who's doing it
there is no fingerprints today it's
tough to find the fingerprints today how
do you go back and see who's behind this
thing here how do you not know these
were
operate you know people who are working
on the inside with the russian
government that are doing this how do
you not know that this is funded you
don't
know that stuff the paper trail to find
a lot of stuff is tough today you don't
know but
why because it's done online the the
hackers
they can find ways to eliminate their
ips so you don't know where it's coming
from and
these guys are becoming so good at what
they're doing today you know
it it uh this reminds me of the cali
cartel back in the
80s 90s right for everything
that pablo escobar and those guys are
those guys for every
element that we put together to attack
them to go after
their networks to you know kill their
their
you know groups everything we did
you know and so think of it like this
you can't wiretap a cell phone right
this is back in the 80s
coming out of the 80s going into the 90s
we figured out how to get up on the
phones
so they went to pagers then we figured
out how to get
on the pagers they take one step
we have to follow it up with two or
three to catch up how long does that
take to catch up by the way
it depends on what it is but it takes a
while okay it's not immediate
you know they're thinking the criminal
element
is this they're constantly thinking of
ways to circumvent
the law circumvent law enforcement and
every time they do that
we have to come up with a way to combat
it in this
this stuff is like star wars
realistically and today
um you know there are kids out there
15 year old kids that are in high
schools
that in in my town for example in bergen
county new jersey
there are kids in high schools that you
know get
visits from the fbi and the secret
service because they just happened to
tap into
you know michelle obama's banking just
for shits and giggles
just tell them just to play
they're playing a game yeah they're
playing a game but that's the
intelligence level of some of these kids
today
and what happens then they go into the
private sectors they go into government
sectors they go into criminal sectors
um and they go out there and do this
stuff so that the genius
of our younger generation when it comes
to this
is incredible um and it's frightening
who's more creative who's more creative
uh cia
fbi uh you know dea
or criminals who was more creative
um the criminals are more creative
because they're there first
they get there first right so they have
to be creative they already know what we
have the ability to do
yeah so they have to get creative to
circumvent that
but i will i will tell you this when the
fbi has a problem
or the cia has a problem they can't
really figure it out
who do they go to boom they go to the
criminals right
they get their informants they get their
sources
they bring in people that can get the
job done
and and sometimes it's it's like in the
classic movie catch me as you can frank
now let me see the guys all right we
can't figure this guy out let's bring
him in get him right let's go get him
and now he's in a
and now he's like one of the more
outspoken people out there talking about
money laundering and washing money and
not using
credit cards roosevelt went to uh joseph
kennedy you know because he's like
listen man the way you can manipulate
the stock market i have to find out what
you're doing to
find the next criminals yeah right and
that's how the whole sec got started
back in the days they have to find out
how would you manipulate the market
today how would you mess with the market
today
but these hackers they're not driven by
the same things that others are driven
by they're not driven by
money they're not driven they're driven
by you know so
some are driven by money some it's not
all of them though but not all of them
yeah some of them are driven by revenge
they're driven by you said what did you
say watch what i'm gonna do or it's a
game you don't think i can do this it's
okay
exactly it's it's a game it's political
it's revenge it's you know it's
financial at least these dark side guys
whoever these guys are they're
flat out saying look man we're just
great at what we do we want money that's
all we care about you give us at least
there being uh
fully full disclosure we want a very
one-dimensional relationship we're very
good at what we do we're going to make
your life a living hell just give us the
money we'll leave you alone
it's crazy what these young kids could
do i think it was like a 15 year old kid
that hacked into twitter or something
like that and started tweeting
under jack dorsey or whatever the
ridiculous story was like that you know
what's scary
is you look at some of the dark side
hackers
who were they hacking they're hacking
police departments
they're hacking police departments
they're hacking government agencies
they're going to police departments and
saying what's their outcome
money money they want paid
you know we're gonna you know we're
gonna shut down your city's ability
to you know to get uh payments
for city electric you know utilities
we're gonna shut that down uh you know
we want a hundred thousand dollars
in bitcoin and we want it by 12 p.m
today
and if you don't do it we're shutting
that ability down so
they look at it like this the city looks
at it like this one
we're not going to grab them we're not
going to catch them we may catch them
later on down the line but we ain't
getting them no time
soon to stop this and two
if they shut our ability down to collect
utility payments from
city residents it's going to cost us
five million dollars over the next two
weeks three weeks a month
give them the hundred thousand and so so
they'll negotiate with terrorists and
pay them that's what you're saying
cyber terrorist cities pay cities are
paid yeah
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye